L
COMPANY.
>> Tammy: WOW, SO THERE YOU GO.
YOU HAVE BEEN IN GOVERNMENT.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE WAYS TO MAKE
THINGS HAPPEN.
WE WORK TO PERSUADE PEOPLE AND
HERE SHE IS THINKING ESPECIALLY
WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN IT WOULD
HAVE AN IMPACT.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THAT?
>> WELL, WHAT SHE IS TALKING
ABOUT IS SHUTTING DOWN AMERICAN
PIPELINES.
TO BRING ENERGY TO HOUSEHOLDS.
TO KEEP HOUSEHOLDS WARM IN THE
WINTER.
KEEP HOUSEHOLDS COOL IN THE
SUMMER.
THEY PROTECT THE ELDERLY AND THE
YOUNG.
I MEAN, THIS IS ABOUT PHYSICAL
SAFETY FOR MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS.
IT'S ABOUT AFFORDABILITY FOR A
BLUE COLLAR FAMILIES.
THIS IS REALLY AN ATTACK ON
WORKING PEOPLE.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE ANOTHER
POINT.
YOU HAVE TO ASK A QUESTION.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT WHO IS
HURTING OUR COUNTRY.
WHAT KIND OF MOVEMENT HOLD UP AS
A LEADER?
ZEN RATES A PERSON LIKE JANE
FONDA.
WHAT SHE DID IN THE VIETNAM WAR
YOU MAY HAVE FORGOTTEN THIS, WAS
SHE VOLUNTEERED HERSELF AS A
TOOL OF NORTH VIETNAMESE
COMMUNIST PROPAGANDA.
SHE DID PROPAGANDA BROADCAST ON
THEIR RADIO STATION ON VIETNAM.
SHE SAT ON THEIR ANTI-AIRCRAFT
BATTERY USED TO SHOOT DOWN
AMERICAN PLANES AND AMERICAN
AIRMEN.
THIS IS BY ANY DEFINITION AND
I'M GOING TO USE THE WORD BY ANY
DEFINITION WHAT SHE DID IN THE
VIETNAM WAR IS TREASON.
AND SHE HELD UP AS A HERO?
>> Tammy: LOOK AID AND
COMFORTING OF THE ENEMY.
IT WAS CLEAR IN THAT REGARD.
AND THIS IS -- WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT -- WELL, IT'S JUST JANE
FONDA OR A ONE OFF SITUATION.
IT'S NOT.
THIS IS A MENTALITY THAT FEEDS
THE MOVEMENT EVEN TO THIS DAY
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT AMERICA LAST
WE ARE NOT KIDDING, ARE WE?
>> NO.
IT'S A MINDSET, JUST LIKE
REFLEXIVELY JANE FONDA RUSHED TO
THE DEFENSE OF THE COMMUNISTS IN
VIETNAM WHO WERE KILLING OUR
BOYS OVERSEAS.
NOW SHE IS RUSHING TO HELP
PEOPLE LIKE VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
LIKE CHINA AND LIKE OTHER
COUNTRIES BY SHUTTING DOWN U.S.
ENERGY.
WHO DOES IT HELP WHEN YOU SHUT
DOWN OUR ENERGY PRODUCTION?
IT HELPS OUR FOREIGN ADVERSARIES
AROUND THE GLOBE.
>> WE HEAR THIS FROM SO MANY
LEFTISTS AND I WANT YOU TO ALSO
HEAR JOY READ.
SHE SAYS A LOT OF SURPRISING
THINGS.
HERE ARE HER COMMENTS BACKING UP
THE VICE PRESIDENT ON THE
BORDER.
LET'S LISTEN TO THIS.
>> THIS IS PERHAPS A POPULAR
OPINION IN THE BUSINESS RIGHT
NOW.
BUT, I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
SOME PERSPECTIVE, THE UNITED
STATES SOUTHERN BORDER WITH
MEXICO IS NOT THE ONLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAT MATTERS TO THE WORLD.
THOSE SEVEN COUNTRIES HAVE A
LONG HISTORY WITH THE UNITED
STATES, MUCH OF IT TROUBLING.
THE UNITED STATES USED MUCH OF
CENTRAL AMERICA AS ESSENTIALLY A
GIANT PLANTATION.
>> Tammy: WOW, HERE YOU HAVE
WOMEN'S LIVES BEING RUINED.
CHILDREN'S LIVES BEING RUINED.
SEX TRAFFICKING, DRUGS COMING
OVER THE BORDER.
BUT IT'S NOT SUCH A GLOBAL ISSUE
SHE SAYS.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IS THERE A MORE
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR ANY COUNTRY
THAN WHETHER OR NOT IT HAS,
DEFENDS AND MAINTAIN AS BORDER?
WHAT NATION AND WHAT SIZZLES HAS
LONG ENDURED THAT FAILED TO
PROTECT AND DEFEND ITS OWN
BORDERS?
IT'S FUNDAMENTAL TO SURVIVAL AS
A COUNTRY, AS A SIZZLES. CIVILI.
SECONDLY WHAT TOO WE THINK THE
ODDS ARE THAT SHE HAS DOORS ON
HER HOMES AND LOCKS ON THOSE
DOORS?
WHAT ARE THE ODDS THAT SHE HAS A
CAR THAT SHE LOCKS THAT SHE
LEAVES IT AT NIGHT.
THIS IS OUR COUNTRY WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND WHAT ABOUT ALL THE PEOPLE AS
YOU MENTIONED THAT ARE RAPED AND
BRUTALIZED ON THE JOURNEY NORTH?
SHE WANTS TO BLAME AMERICAN
COLONIALISM?
DO YOU KNOW WHETHER A CAUSED
POVERTY?
DO YOU KNOW WHAT CAUSED MAYHEM
THROUGHOUT THE WESTERN
HEMISPHERE AND IN PARTICULAR
LATIN AMERICA?
LEFTIST GOVERNMENTS AND
SOCIALIST POLICIES AND MARXIST
POLICIES.
>> Tammy: EXACTLY THAT.
>> DESTROYED THE ECONOMIES OF
LATIN, AMERICA, AND THEN THEY
WANT TO EXPORT THESE POLICIES
HERE.
>> Tammy: THIS IS WHAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE ESCAPING.
THIS IS WHY WE ARE A SHINY CITY
ON THE HILL.
LAST HOPE FOR PEOPLE ESCAPING
WHAT THOSE NATIONS DID THROUGH
SOCIALISM CONTINUE TO TRY TO DO.
WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH STEVEN,
GREAT STUFF AND AMERICAN FIRST
LEGAL DOING GREAT WORK.
>> THA